little edition of pft live p-f-t-o-t
whatever you want to call it we're just
with you for a couple of minutes because
we were doing our pix podcast and we saw
some news that we need to react to chris
the minnesota vikings who traded for
defensive end yannick and gawkway just
before the start of the season have now
flipped him to the ravens but it's not
really a flip when you buy
high
and sell
lower than what you bought this is cut
your losses this is fire sale this is we
stink and we know it right let's get
what we can and move on yeah that's
exactly right they know after last
week's loss it's over they're not going
anywhere
they're not going to the playoffs this
year start getting assets and building
for the future they gave it a shot with
training for yannick and gawkway they
wanted to see what they had okay now
they know it's over and then you got the
other team on the other end of the
spectrum where's going wait we're a
super bowl team we have we need one more
piece here to help us get over the hump
of our kryptonite right and the kansas
city chiefs and all that i really think
that's what it comes down to baltimore
we know the defense is awesome mike but
we've seen against the chiefs and even
last week against carson wentz who don't
have great talent you know they have to
blitz too much baltimore they have to
leave their secondary vulnerable so much
and i think they realize like we're not
going to beat the cream of the crop in
the afc or patrick mahomes an afc
championship game if we have to blitz
five and six and seven guys all the time
to get after him so i really think
that's what it's all about brilliant
move by the ravens way to go
yeah and look for the vikings they gave
up a second round pick in 2021 and a
conditional fifth rounder in 2022 they
get back a third round pick in 2021
conditional fifth rounder in 2022 here's
the reality though the viking second
rounder is going to be high the ravens
third rounder is going to be low this is
almost a two-round drop not just one for
the vikings but this is get what you can
for a guy who was going to walk away
anyway as a free agent there's no
commitment that the franchise tag could
be they weren't going to tag him though
that's what i've been told they're not
going to tag him who knows what the
ravens will do the vikings definitely
are going to tag him for now but uh it
was a mistake it didn't work he's been
good the vikings stink right and
it makes you wonder what's going to come
next for the vikings is this the only
trade or is this the first of
potentially several as they maybe sell
off some pieces and try to load the
cannon for next year yeah no i i think
that i i would bet on that you know
that's i think with the the way the
salary cap is pending for 2021 and all
that it could lead us to one of the more
exciting trade deadlines we've seen you
know in recent history because also like
like we've seen here
we have some teams that we all think are
super bowl contenders have a chance to
do that who have real needs this year
too to where it's like oh they have a
spot where they need one more guy to get
over the top or you know they have this
one issue so that's where it's really
interesting to me and man i mean the
other thing that just jumps out you know
that that ravens football team but class
campbell and yannick and gawkway from
jacksonville they get reunited together
i mean that now baltimore can do
anything they want they can you know
rush four drop seven in the coverage
know they're going to be able to get
pressure if they want to get big and
have to play a run style type of team
they'll be able to do that because they
have tons of big people too so it just
makes them more versatile able to match
up against different opponents and i
think the real big thing is to match up
against the really good quarterbacks in
football that they might have to face
when things get really real
raven steelers titans chiefs the best
four teams in the afc the ravens get a
little bit better today as they prepare
for their stretch run coming out of the
buy coming up this weekend vikings were
on a buy two perfect time to do some
business we'll be keeping track of all
other business that gets done as the
trade deadline approaches in just 13
days thanks for some of your time
actually 12 days thanks for some of your
time we'll see you every weekday morning
on peacock and nbcsn for pft live
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights from nbc
sports